i am happy to welcome mr silver ceballos
mr ceballos is a biotechnologist by
profession from the technological de
costa rica
and graduate student in microbiology at
the university of costa rica with almost
10 years of being involved in biological
sciences working on several research
projects
he is currently working at the center
for research in cellular and molecular
biology together with the host
microorganism symbiosis research group
led by dr adrian pindo tomas
aware that the fourth industrial
revolution is biological he has
professional interests in microbial
ecology bio bioprospecting symbiosis
secondary metabolite biosynthesis
and synthetic biology
he is the co-founder of rosalind
inventions a stem education company
dedicated to creating tools and programs
for school and college youth teachers
and professionals in the natural and
health sciences
so please join me in welcoming mr
ceballos
thank you very much laura
for having me here i have the
opportunity to show a little bit about
our work in bioinformatics teaching
so um
to start i'm going to share my my screen
can you confirm please
that you are seeing
my presentation
yes we can see your presentation thank
you very much
so um
good afternoon everybody um the
the title for for my speaking today is
breaking barriers for scientific
education in latin america
um i'm going to introduce myself really
quickly um
as laura said i'm a biotechnology
engineer from technological costa rica
and right now i'm finishing my master's
degree in the university of costa rica
specifically at the faculty of
microbiology in which i work in a
research group dedicated to the study of
symbiosis or interactions between
insects and
bacteria specifically bacteria that are
are um
capable to produce antibiotics right now
i'm working with fungus growing ants and
it's symbiotic bacteria
which is called sodonocardia
i'm also um a very creative person i i
i loved music like doing it for a long
time and i uh something that
characterizes myself is to
how art or
or this creative can combine
with science and i'm going to show you
how it looks like in here from costa
rica
um
also i'm a co-founder of wrestling
innovations uh in which i develop as the
developer i'm in charge of designing uh
some of the scientific programs that we
have and also about all the technical
specs
that comes from the challenge of
designing and executing those programs
in here
and to start um we are a stem education
company dedicated to promoting science
in youth through experimental strength
programs completely 100 experimental
these programs are
focused to
um
high school students for example and
also university students or we have a
few experience with kids also
and before the pandemic starts we were
developing a lot of workshops in which
we engage youth students with for
example activities such as
isolating microbes or doing experiments
with microbes and also with fungi
but then
the pandemic starts and as as as you all
know we have like a lot of trouble
with presidentiality so basically um our
our model
uh just got disrupted we um no longer
have the availability of
of young students
or
professionals also
so we have to transition for a more
virtual
program that works for for us and also
for the persons
um and here we come to with a via to
develop
a scientific program that is dedicated
to teach bioinformatics
for public of costa rica primarily
but we are looking to expand it to other
countries as
in latin america as well
and i'm going to share with you some
some of the background uh and also
challenges that we have uh in our
country which i hope that many of you
also could familiarize with those um
with those challenges
first of all
uh
mathematics is not a new field we all
know that it's a field that has more
than 20 years developing also aided by
the emerging of new sequencing
technologies and computational
capacity but it feels very new to us
we for example
many bachelors in life science here
do not have bioinformatic courses in the
programs and if they have they have just
one course
uh also there is a lack of well-trained
professors in bioinformatics and there
are very few researchers that actually
does
or employ bioinformatics in their
research
also um
both teaching and learning by
bioinformatics could be very difficult
especially because of some of the
backgrounds
topics that are
employed to teach bioinformatics and
and concepts in cell biology
biochemistry and molecular biology could
be
very distant to
many early students
which do not have a proper background
so
basically we we have like this idea
to um to design a program
to engage uh
beginners and early-stage students
unprofessional with bioinformatics
um
in in a way that uh it would be like a
first step that could derive in more
learning opportunities maybe for example
from platforms such as crusada or maybe
some international programs that are
also
available but we want to focus in here
with these uh public just beginners and
early stage students
so we have like
various challenges that we need to
overcome in order to um to make like
these persons not only to like
informatics but also to understand it
and
and
want to continue to pursue like
knowledge in this field
so
we design a program that is basically
conform of four things uh first of all i
assign chronic sessions in which
we have like a master class we view some
concepts review tools um we also view
case studies and some analysis that we
do that we do with those tools
we also engage with activities and some
work with some homeworks in which we
have extracurricular activities
dedicated to the strength some of the
techniques or maybe some of the
activities that we already see we have
lectures also to expand knowledge we
have evaluations and we have also um a
mentoring file in which
the participants are allowed to
are allowed to make uh questions so we
deliver a very quick um answers to them
to guide them through our program
and also uh we use google classroom as
uh as a platform to unify all these
unified for example like the
the classes the videos
um the extracurricular activities the
lectures
and it has given us like very
good results with the public that engage
in our program
also
there are some things that we wanted to
to make uh
doing like
to introduce in our program because of
um
personal experience with these tools um
in the past but also because of their
potential and i want to introduce many
benchland because it's like a
cloud-based informatics platform for
life science and it's a very good one i
have been following benjalin since its
start i don't know it's like eight years
ago maybe
but it's great all the the capacities
that it has right now and the upgrades
that have been also introduced
um it's great for managing for example
biological data uh you could have like
folders in here
and also
upload a lot of of biological sequence
and you can visualize very easily create
multiple sequence alignments or and it
has other features
that works very well as preliminary
efforts
and also we have like some online
bioinformatics tools such as the the
french portal of phylogeny um in which
we have like tools for trimming or doing
multiple sequence alignments and also to
create a phylogenetic trees
which um
are very adequate for our purpose of
teaching
bioinformatics
and also we employ um this third open uh
tool which is itil or
on the tree of life international sphere
of life
for me
trees so basically we are um like
combining uh different tools to employ
these programs google classroom for the
resources uh but also eventually for the
managing of all the data that is uh
that is given to the students
and also um
a set of tools that are
publicly and anyone can use them they're
open source and also these tools that is
uh well
known and used uh in the visualization
of other genetic data
so i'm going to give you right now like
a a really quick overview with topics
and the case studies that we use
to teach bioinformatics we i hope that
uh could inspire many
other initiatives
this the most
so it has worked really great for us
so first of all like we have this
program in space of four sessions
uh the decision number one is pretty
focused on databases and management of
biological data we use a case study uh
which is the
the virus that is the cause of the
pandemic
and also um
what we do
um pretty basically is to explore
um mutations on the spike protein so
ncbi has a really great portal to
look on information about
this sarskof2 virus and we focus uh
specifically on
on spike sequences in which uh we review
a question such as what is
bioinformatics what a biological
database and what is the the virus and
how does it look like so
basically we obtain a lot of sequence
from these viruses that are publicly
available and comes from different uh
parts of the world latin america united
states europe africa
uh asia also australia
and
we can use those data to
explore mutations and we can up upload
the data to benchlink we can quickly
very quickly observe its sequence a lot
of residues and also identify
mutations in here
so that is like our first approach to
the use of pension and prevalence is we
wanna uh it's a basic very very robust
skill
that we teach in this program how to to
get all the advantage of a platform such
as pension
we then have like a second a second
session which is called genetics and
evolution we in here we start by doing
some
more advanced analysis in here
we
try to obtain sequence we we focus uh
primarily on the like the searching of
sequence in databases how you obtain
those sequence you upload them and you
manage them in folders but in here we
advance a step further in
for example in constructing
multiple sequence alignments and how to
visualize those alignments and we use a
case study based on a foodborne
pathogens
and why are foodborne pathogens because
it's really easy to
to maybe understand
the issue here i think um
well it's it's a very important um issue
around the world but also um i think
everybody has uh one in life like an
experience with diarrhea and also we
explored that
this thing that diarrhea is like a very
critical disease
uh around the world and it's caused by
bacteria so we
we try to also to explore further uh
these are microbes that cause
diarrhea such as the coliforms for
example
so we use uh questions such as how to
construct a database
that we can explore later how to or what
is like also multiple sequence alignment
how we do that and what is the
evolutionary origins of coliforms those
bacteria that are well known for causing
disease and are well transmitted in in
food
so basically um
we we try to to
also to obtain a lot of sequences
from coliforms uh from the gene bank
database we also construct and correct a
database and we engage in activities
such as constructing multiple sequence
alignments in math which is a pretty
famous tool and also to start uh looking
at preliminary phy login so in here um
we also try to to expand you know on the
under relationships of
for example which is our two species
uh that causes some debate because some
microbiologists
believe that they are one species that
just have like a speciation event and
other microbiologists uh tend to
argument that they are different species
and also to look at other um types of
bacteria that are pretty interesting
just as
there's in a pestis which is uh one of a
pandemic bacteria in the past
and we engage in here like doing some
starting phylogeny
you know like
starting to grasp concepts about how
phylogeny works
and how to also interpret phylogenetic
trees
and this case also has like a a really
cool activity in which
the students try to obtain
different sequences from other organisms
and try to include those sequences into
the database and try to reconstruct
again a multiple sequence alignment try
to reconstruct
another philogenic tree and then compare
the new phylogenetic tree with the older
one to see how does it uh differ
and what does it happen what does just
happen in the analysis
and we have uh two other two other
sessions dedicated exclusively to
explore
uh phylogenetics a little bit more
and for this we use a model organism
that is called cost regulated facilities
for a variety of reasons
first of all because
um it is a very important uh pathogen
here in costa rica
and also it's internationally is well
known as a model of organism because it
produces
various toxins which
um play a big role in pathology and also
well in countries such as united states
like it is a very big big problem not
only because of the fatalities of that
disease but also because of the
recurrence which produces itself in
an economic cost
so um we explore questions such as how
do toxins look like from a phytogenic
perspective or are toxins from um
crosstaling clustering that is
deficiently derived from costa rica are
similar to other toxins from isolates
around the world
and also in here we have a pretty
interesting future in which we um
we basically we employ genomes from
costa rican isolates that have been
isolated from um
an outbreak
that uh happened to like 2010
around 2010
uh and a lot of from those isolates like
a few of them um
got sequence and the the data is like
publicly available
so
this is
this is something that we want to to
like like some kind of signature to
employ uh sequences that are uh derived
from our country uh not also because it
is like important it's public funding uh
funded by the states but also because uh
it is very important for us to
engage in science outreach and
and to let people know about some
efforts that are
known
in some of our universities so we employ
genome data from these uh closely
audited deficit isolates
to um to look for toxin sequences and
then managing those in in benchline for
example but also use it use them to
construct
phylogenies of the toxins
and we also include
a database like a basic database
with a reference organism such as out
groups in order to improve our phylogeny
so this could be like a very good figure
of how the phylogeny of these toxins
look like in which isolates of costa
rica
uh tend to group in these clades
and this one's here
and in in the
and also in the last uh in the last
session uh we try to create a
typification of clustering it is
deficiently used in multi multiple
sequence alignment which is a very
common
technique used in epidemiology
and so we basically
teach the students to how to obtain
housekeeping gene sequence from genomes
and how to use them to construct uh
multiple
seek vocals to construct the sequences
that are employed later in the in this
type of analysis
and we try to answer if these genomes
the phylogeny of these genomes using
mlst looks similar to the toxin
phylogeny which we already know that we
have differences the phylogeny the
genome phenology is very uh
it's very similar
the isolates but the toxins of those
isolates is very different so it's it's
a very nice result to illustrate how
how some features of genomes such as
toxins have a different evolutionary
path as the the genome or the general
chromosome it has different uh
evolutionary pressures and and that is
something that is really really
interesting to to learn
so uh some conclusion about our
experience is that um
approximately like one year to teach
this program where down 50 students
have passed through let's make
bioinformatics
also we try to offer this program to
university students and professionals
from different countries which are
interested for example in pursuing
mastery degrees
and also um
as uh as the professor or instructor of
this program we have we have
seen that the implementation of cases
studies and model organisms improve both
teaching but also learning like it's
more
it's it's more concrete to illustrate
some
how
bioinformatic analysis can be employed
in
in in different uh
cases scenarios in real life
and also um
well always the alumni share like a
desire to continue learning
bioinformatics so it's like a good sign
for us
so that's um
so that's like the summary of of
of this program that we
share with you
and also
that is continually offered to
students here in costa rica
so thank you very much for your time
great thank you so much mr tobias that
was a very informative talk
all right we have a few questions for
you
um number one with so much antibiotic
antimicrobial resistance happening
because of the overuse of antibiotics
do you think bioinformatics can be
useful to track and overcome this
challenge
yes um first of all i think it's like a
global phenomenon uh we are starting to
to
obtain isolates that have a resistance
also we have as a country we have
different efforts
to survey for microbials
that present resistance also
well i personally might
participate in
a big research project that is
focused on discovering novel
antibiotics basically we have a very big
bioprospection operation that uh isolate
and obtain microbes from insects and
then test them against a
panel of clinical pathogens in order to
look for interesting isolates that are
then transferred to
a university in the united states so
so
it is like a great um necessity on all
around the world to
not only to survey for
uh resistant patterns but also to look
for
novel sources of antibiotics
and what was the second question excuse
me
yeah so um the second question is what
are some of the ways that students from
south america can find mentors
that can expand their horizons
and help them gain insights into
specialized topics like bioinformatics
so
some of these
bioinformatics analysis are well known
or applied to
this both this case of antimicrobial
resistance but also in epidemiology
in research also
i believe
universities are making an effort to
include bioinformatics in their programs
but it's a long it's a long way
to to get to that
so um
i believe for example if you well one of
the purpose of this course is just to to
bring a starting point
um and i think that is very important if
you want to to engage in bioinformatics
like to have a good starting point in
which you like can uh
have like a little grasp of the concepts
that are or the concepts or the
techniques or the tools that are taught
in biopharma so you could advance in
other types of programs and i think uh
uh programs such as as the ones offered
in court seda are like a very good uh
second stage
to
um explore like more different tools and
also start in coding which is like the
final
i think it's the final objective i i
myself
do bioinformatic analysis
in
clusters and
use like the coding stuff but if you are
an early stage student like
it's going to
maybe you're going to get afraid of the
corroding and and maybe that also um
it started turns you down
so
that's like the barrier that we are
trying to
to break
that it's coding is it's not uh always i
know it's it's kind to be difficult
uh you have time and a lot of practice
but
it's easier to start coding if you have
like a good grasp
of what's going on